thank you so much for the introduction
so again my name is Brad I'm a developer
programs engineer at Google and so what
that means is that I spend a lot of time
working very closely with developers
attending conferences and just speaking
with you and learning about the things
that you may like your dislike about
some of the projects that we have going
on
so I specifically focus in the areas of
machine learning and Big Data and one of
those projects that happens to fall into
those categories is tensorflow so today
I'm gonna tell you a bit about tender
flow 2.0 how you can get started with it
as well as some of the changes from the
tender flow one that X versions so just
before we we dive in I would just like
to get a show of hands here who here has
done machine learning before in any
capacity just play your hand out okay
cool that's a good chunk of you what
about deep learning specifically okay
tensorflow
have you used it just any either version
okay awesome
so let's let's get into it just to give
you an idea of what we're going to
specifically discuss today I'm gonna
introduce tensor flow and just tell you
what it is generally I'm just so that
we're all on the same page here I'm then
going to discuss tensor flow at Google
and how we're using it on some of the
projects that we're working on will then
discuss why Python is so important to
tensor flow and have the two go
hand-in-hand will then discuss tender
flow 2.0 and some of the features
available to it as well as how to
upgrade if you're using tensor flow 1
dot X right now I'll tell you how you
can move to 2 dot o and then getting
started just if you haven't used hundred
flow at all you know just some of the
resources that are available for you to
continue your learning and to use tensor
flow 2.0 ok so what is tensor flow it is
an open source deep learning library
that is developed at Google I was
released in 2015 but it actually existed
a little bit before that we were using
it for projects internally but then we
released it as an open source project in
2015 and so what is it well tensor flow
is a it's a Python framework that
includes a lot of utilities for helping
you write deep neural networks deep
neural networks of course being the the
main component of what makes deep
learning what it is and so a lot of deep
learning involves using mathematics
statistics
algebra and then low level optimizations
with your system and so what tensorflow
actually does is it removes a lot of
those abstractions away from you so that
you only have to worry about actually
writing your model and it's so it just
takes a lot of those what otherwise
would be complicated steps and just
makes it super easy for you to use
tender flow provides support for both
GPUs and TP use these are hardware
accelerators that are GPUs and TPU
specifically work heavily with linear
algebra and mathematical computations
and so tender fill is able to utilize
these this hardware right out of the box
so that you can get those the benefits
of using these using these today tender
flow has over 2,000 contributors all
over the world and the the 2.0 beta
version was released just last month in
June so as I mentioned tensorflow was
released publicly in 2015 and since then
we've just seen massive growth both
internal and internal use and also
throughout the community and so we're
continuously adding new features to this
here's just a bit of a brief timeline to
show you some of the changes that were
done over time and I mentioned tender
flows being used all over the world I
love looking at this graph just to see
how tender flow is able to help
developers build their their machine
learning systems just globally it's
really blows my mind as I mentioned you
know we have two over 2000 contributors
and just there's a lot of activity in
the repo which is super exciting and
yeah
so tension flow is used all over the
world but it's also used internally we
use it to power all of the machine
learning and AI that we have going on
inside Google and so I just want to tell
you about some of the examples and how
we're actually using this stuff so one
of the first things I like to talk about
is how our data centers are powered
using AI so given that we are Google and
that the scale that we operate at we
have a lot of data centers that do a lot
of computations and use a lot of power
and so we're actually able to do is use
AI and tensorflow to help optimize the
the usage of these data centers both to
reduce bandwidth make sure that network
connections are optimized reduce power
consumption as well and this just you
know helps helps the environment and
just is really you know a better way to
have these data centers actually be
running so we're using tens are flowing
to do that we're also using these
technologies for global localization in
Google Maps so for those of you who may
have used Google Maps before you might
know that we have an augmented reality
feature where if you're walking through
a city such as basil then you can use it
to help you get from point A to point B
directly on the map and you consider
directly on your phone and you can see
an example of that here how the the
directions are actually just showing up
on your screen so you know which street
to go down I'm usually using tensor flow
and artificial intelligence and then
we're also using it heavily also in
Google Maps but within the Google pixel
itself to help optimize some of the
software that we have going on there so
in this use case we're talking about the
portrait mode on the Google pixel which
helps you blur out the the background of
an image so that you get to focus in
specifically on the whatever it is that
you want to focus on and then here's an
example of an audio synthesizer and so
what we actually have here is
effectively a cast pad for those of you
may have used that before but the idea
here is that you can slide you can slide
the cursor around on the pad and it will
actually generate music and this is done
beyond training on an algorithm that was
using tons of flow to train it we're
also using tensor flow and AI for
medical research
so in this use case we have two images
here one the one on the left is what we
might consider a retinal image of a
healthy eye and the one on the right is
an image of an eye that has what we call
diabetic retinopathy and so we're
actually able to do is there's research
going on that's using tensor flow and
computer vision to actually predict
which one of these is a healthy eye
versus an unhealthy eye and then this is
probably my favorite example of the
bunch this here is we're using AI and
tempted flow to help us actually predict
whether or not foreign or whether or not
objects and space are planets and just a
brief astronomy lesson of how this works
if you imagine that you have if you if
you look at something like the Sun this
might be hard for you to actually see
but if you imagine you have a large body
of light and something moves in front of
it then the brightness of that object
will decrease ever so slightly but
enough that we have we can use
telescopes and whatnot to actually
pick up on the differences in those
brightness and we can then graph that as
we see here on the right and then using
using artificial intelligence we can
actually predict whether or not those
fluctuations in the brightness results
is due to it being an actual planet or
another object so we're this is another
example of the sort of research that
word that we're doing okay so I talked
about some examples and now I just want
to briefly need to discuss why python is
so important and why we use Python as
the why we're using Python with tons of
flow so python is a great choice for
scientific commuting of course it's you
know it's very easy to use I would hope
everyone agrees which is why you're all
here and also it has a super rich
ecosystem for doing a data science you
know you have tools such as numpy
scikit-learn and pandas and we and if we
look at the success of these you know a
lot of these do stem from the the
package and i'm pie itself enough pie is
great because as the performance of c
but it has the high level API and python
and the east of use of python and so
when we went into flow was being built
the idea is we wanted it to have the
simplicity that numpy has so with that
it has the performance of c but also the
ease of use of python and that's why
we're actually able to use Python for
this because we're able to leverage the
best of both worlds with both of these
so let's talk about 2.0 and some of the
changes that that have come with it so
for those of you who may have used
tensorflow
1 dot X before you might have realized
that it's you know it's great it's
powerful and there's a lot that it can
do but it definitely had its
shortcomings you know I'll be the first
to admit these of course just having
used these personally you know some of
the things that I personally found
frustrating we're using session dot run
just it did necessarily feel super
pythonic as well as having multiple
different ways to do the same thing so a
an RNN layer as improved was implemented
multiple different ways and how would
you know which one to use it could
sometimes be a little frustrating and so
both of these things that I mentioned
were actually addressed intention flow
to dotto so the redundancy in the API
was cleaned up a lot so there's only you
know there's there should be one way to
do most things so we're of course
focusing on making sure that we remove
all the redundancies as we continue to
develop the project and also a session
dot run
has been removed as we use a concept
called eager execution which effectively
means that your tensorflow code runs
just like numpy code and I will show you
an example of that in just a moment and
then another change is that we've
introduced Karras as the main high-level
API
who here is used caressed before just a
quick show of hands ok so I don't know
about you but Karis is personally it's I
love using Karis it's super easy to use
and so we've actually taken Karis and
adopted that into the tensorflow project
comm and again more on that a little bit
later we also want to make sure that
tensorflow is powerful and that it's
flexible it's usable for research
purposes for production purposes and we
really want to make sure that we can get
this into the hands of as many people as
possible and help as many people as
possible with their projects so it's
reflexil
and then also given that it operates at
this given that we've tested tensorflow
at the at Google scale you know we know
that it works at this scale so we you
know it's it's super scalable and it can
should be able to use it for a free use
case as well we're also able to deploy
tender float code anywhere or what we're
at least hoping to do is make it a
continuing to make this as flexible as
it can be we want to make sure that you
have different options for where you can
run your tonnes or flow models so the
first example is on tender flow extended
which is a Python library that you can
actually run on your servers to
production eliezer models we also have
package called tensorflow light which
lets you run your tensorflow models on
on edge devices and then you can also
run your tensorflow models in the
browser using tons of flow tend to flow
Jas and so why is it that we're able to
do this and how is it that we're
actually able to do this so we use
something called a saved model which is
the format that you can output your
Tenzer flow model and once you've
trained it so if for those of you who
have done data science before and who
have built a machine learning model you
know that you start off by reading and
processing with data you then apply
layers to it via TF Kerris or using tons
of flow estimators which are back box
models you then choose to distribute it
either over just the CPUs on your laptop
or GPUs or GPUs on a cluster but once
you do all that and once you have the
model actually trained you can export
this into what we call a saved model and
this saved model is a universal
format that you can then load into any
one of the deployment options that I
mentioned earlier so in this case you
can use tender flow extended and tender
flow serving to be able to run it on
servers you can use tensor for light for
edge of devices as I mentioned and then
tend to float yes to run it in the
browser but also we have other language
bindings available a lot of these are
community driven but for some of the
examples we have C Java go c-sharp rust
and R and using the saved model it lets
you actually run these from these
anywhere some other packages that exist
in the tundra flow ecosystem are form or
I guess a nice use cases so I have some
examples listed here
TF probability TF agents a tender to
tender and so these really less I
mentioned just exist for these more
specific use cases for instance TF
agents is a package that exists to do
reinforcement learning and it has some
higher-level API is stacked on top of
tons of flow to help you build
reinforcement learning TF text is used
for natural language processing using
tensorflow
and so there's a whole long list of
these and definitely worth checking out
if you have a specific use case that you
want to use tensorflow for we also are
introducing tensorflow hub which is you
can loosely consider that the github of
models in that you can actually store
you can store and download pre-built
models here and you can actually get
started working with tons or flow and
machine learning using using these
models you can modify them and you can
do whatever you want with these but this
is just a place for you to start start
working with machine learning so earlier
I mentioned that you can use tensorflow
to oh just like numpy and so you know
for those of you who have used bone pipe
before this sort of this code may look
sort of familiar to you and that we're
creating just a two by two matrix in
this case and then just doing a
multiplication on it and then we can
print it out immediately we couldn't
actually do this with ten to flow one
dot X you had to then it you had to
initialize the variables you had to then
run the graph and there was just a bit
more involved than just creating the
matrix and then doing the mathematical
operation and then printing it so this
is definitely a really really nice
feature and just creates makes it much
more easy to use so then just to talk
about some of the specifics of what it
was
what's gone and then what's actually new
so I keep mentioning this but session
dot run is gone we don't have to worry
about that anymore
a lot of the tender flow specific
operators such as conditionals if
statements while statements that you had
to use tensorflow specific operations
floor have actually been removed you can
just use normal Python code and there's
a reason for that which involves using a
new feature that I'm going to mention in
just a second but the last thing I also
want to mention is gone is a TF docking
trip the reason for this is that the
packed the the project just got so large
it just so much involvement from the
community that we had to actually just
remove it from the base build it would
just it was just it's too much memory so
it still exists but it has been removed
just went from a if you just dip in salt
under flow you won't necessarily get it
anymore but then some of the things that
are new include eager execution enabled
by default so this allows you to run
tender flow using a temp is style
caris is the main high-level API and
then take a TF dot function which is a
Python decorator that lets you run your
regular Python code using while loops
and your own if statements just in
Python but it will actually get compiled
down through tons of flow code and we'll
talk a little bit more about that in
just a moment as well so the next thing
I want to talk about is TF that Carris
and so I asked earlier who here is used
Kerris and you know I personally
mentioned that I really like Karis and
so the tens of folk community agrees and
so what we're actually doing is we've
joined or we've implemented the carrots
API into tensorflow itself as the main
high-level API and so what does that
actually mean um for those of you who
have used carrots before you may notice
it's Terrace serves as an API spec so
it's not in it of itself an engine it
actually relies on using something like
at engine flow or Theano as the backend
so all we've done is we've taken the API
spec of Karass and just moved it into
tensorflow the two projects do exist
separately still but they are very
closely related so if you want to just
use regular carrots with whatever
back-end you'd like to use you could
just do pip install carrots but then if
you wanted to actually and then do
import carrots but if you wanted to use
tensorflow specifically you can just you
to install tons or flow and then from
tons of
in port caris and the experience should
be more or less the same and so when
you're actually using Karis with tons of
flow there's two ways that I like to
describe that you can get started using
this and so one of them I say is what's
called a for beginners the other one is
what I say is called for experts they're
more or less interchangeable and I
actually like the beginners method more
but it just depends on your use case so
if you're using the beginners method the
way that you would do this is you would
import a Cara sequential model and then
just add the layers row by row so each
one of these actually represents a layer
of your model so in this case it's just
five lines of code and you have a model
built once you have this you then
compile the model which just essentially
makes sure that the the model or the
layers line up and that the input and
output sizes are correct and then you
provide your optimizer your loss
function and then the metrics that you
want to optimize for you then fit it on
your training data and then evaluate it
on your test data so this is using the
beginners method and then there's also
the the experts method as we say so this
is effectively using Python sub classing
and this allows you to inherit the tea
of Karis top model class to then create
a model often scratch and so this gives
you a bit more customized ability and
then you just add a call function and
then you're able to treat this like you
would use Karis layers otherwise and so
what's what's the difference between
these two I mean we talked about it
briefly here but just to give you just a
general idea if you're using the
beginners method which we call the
symbolic method we're using the Kara
sequential your model is a graph of
layers anything that compiles will run
and that tender flow actually helps you
debug by catching the errors at compile
time so this removes a lot of the
debugging away from you and just makes
the code I guess a bit easier to develop
but then in an instance where you may
want to use the imperative method or
what we call the experts method your
model is Python bytecode so it runs just
like python code would you have complete
flexibility and control over what it is
that you're actually building but of
course with that it becomes a bit harder
to debug a bit harder to maintain and
there's definitely pros and cons of
using each method it really just depends
on what your specific use cases
so next I want to talk about TF dot
function so I mentioned earlier that
this is something that lets you run
Python code just as you normally would
and what do I mean by that
so so let's say here that you just have
a function here we're just having a
function that calls a just calls an LS
TM cell from a deep learning from a deep
neural network so if we have a benchmark
here you know we'll see that this take
would take let's say a point zero three
seconds but what we're actually able to
do to convert this and do tensor flow
code is add this TF that function
decorator just an extra line of code and
you'll actually see that we have about a
nine times speed up here from this
example but the idea is is that you can
do this on any any Python code that you
have and so the reason that this is
possible is that we're able to use a
technology called autograph
so what it will do is it will take any
Python function you have and as I
mentioned convert it into the
appropriate underflow code and if you
wanted to see what that looked like you
can use the TF thoughta graph to code
function and it will take this function
here and it will change it into this you
don't need to know how this works
this really isn't important for
necessarily building the model but it
could sometimes be interesting to
actually see what's going on underneath
the hood so next up we'll talk about
distribution strategies so I mentioned
how we want tensorflow to be flexible
and scalable and how you can use it over
a different hardware environments so
let's say that you have this model here
that you may have just built locally on
your laptop if you want to then take
this you know let's say you train this
on a couple hundred rows just to make
sure that it works and that you have
something reasonable that's working
before you actually deploy this onto a
larger scale if you wanted to then take
this and then move it over to whatever
Hardware cluster you have set up all
you'd have to do is just add it within
the scope of a distribution strategy and
so distribution strategies are
effectively ways for you to just take
take the code that you have and deploy
it over you know over your hardware
cluster and so in this case we're using
the marriage strategy what this does is
if you have let's say four GPUs it will
just take the same model and just copy
them over all the different GPUs there's
different ways to do this you can take a
large model and split it up over the
multiple GPUs this is a little bit
outside the scope of this talk but in
this case we're just using that to me
strategy for this example the next thing
you want to talk about is tender flow
datasets
this is one of my personal favorite
features I think it just helps
developers get up and going with machine
learning much faster so for those of you
who you know may have worked with data
before you know that it can sometimes be
very difficult to actually get a good
data set to work with models are only as
good as the data I like to say and so
what we actually have is a bunch of data
sets available for you to use within the
TF the tensor flow data sets package and
so you there's a list of these that I'll
show in the next slide but the idea is
you just you load whatever data set it
is that you want to load you can then
split up the training and the test data
sets and then you can take this data and
plug it into any any model that you want
and so I'm using the cats versus dogs
example here but we have a whole long
list of them most of they're all
available at NJ flow dot org forward
slash data sets some examples here
include ones that you may have seen
before
we have M mist we have a CFR ten image
net that the Titanic data set so some of
these might seem familiar but again if
you're interested in seeing the entire
library of what we have available tend
to float org forward slash data sets so
let's say you're using tensorflow index
and you want to actually upgrade to two
data how can you do that so we have a
bunch of migration guides available on
our website
tons of flow org so that would
definitely be the first place that I
recommend going to if you want to learn
how to do this we also have a library
available called TF comput be one and
what that will do is that some as some
of the api's are deprecated in 2.0 we do
have this library available for you to
actually gain access to some of the
older api's if you're not ready to fully
move away from those this is also mostly
relevant using the the TF upgrade be to
script and so what this will do is you
can execute this on top of any Python
script and it will take the tf1 Dex code
and actually convert it to 2.0 code
similar to if any of you have used the
Python 2 to 3 script before it sort of
does the same thing and with that it'll
it'll tell you what was actually changed
between the two versions and then it
will also implement it yeah I'll rename
it and
to show you what was actually changed
inside of the scripts themselves so if
you're just curious about how to get
started generally with tensorflow again
I keep mentioning this but I definitely
go to the website at times of flow org
but also if you want to just get started
today you can install it now just using
pip install - you double dash Pretenders
below so feel free to do this at our at
the conclusion of the talk tender fluid
org we have tons of resources available
for you kool abs introductions
documentation api specs all of this is
available here we also have partnerships
with Udacity and Coursera we have
tensorflow courses specifically designed
to help you get started so I definitely
recommend taking a look at these if
you're interested in a deep dive with
world-class instructors we also work
with deep learning a I which is run by
Angie wing who is you know very active
in the machine one of the biggest names
in the machine learning community today
we're also on github of course so if
you're interested in actually getting
involved with the project definitely
take a look at the the github repository
and you know we'd love to hear your
feedback or just if you want to add your
features or anything and just get
involved in the open source project by
all means we'd love to have you and then
lastly I just want to talk about two
extra projects that we have going on in
the tension flow community so these are
Swift for Tenzer flow and then tens of
float j/s which actually mentioned
earlier so these projects are actually
so Swift for tender flow is a movement
to actually use Swift to develop machine
learning models and so Swift in it of
itself has become increasingly popular
in the data science community for its
ability to what people argue is fix a
lot of the shortcomings that come with
Python
it's definitely debatable but I think
it's super interesting so I definitely
recommend you checking it out if you're
curious and then tender flow dot Jas
will allow you to actually run machine
learning models using javascript in the
browser or you can also run them on
servers using node works with both
regular JavaScript and node so super
interesting and again if you're curious
I definitely check that out as well
and with that I you know I she would
call to action to go build so definitely
go and install the project continue to
learn about this and let us know
what you'd yeah what you think so thank
you all for listening and I'll stick
around for a few minutes for anyone
asked questions thanks okay question
time can you raise your hand if you'd
like to raise a question please no
questions surely there are okay thank
you very much for that yeah so for some
the information about 2.0 it's very
useful to know something that I'm always
wondering about it's how people actually
kind of curate the the information they
got get out of that kind of training you
know the the the training that you're
doing kind of the the improvement on the
process over time and how they kind of
yeah asaji is kind of curate where do
they store other model one of the models
locally say and how do they evaluate
which model has been performing the best
for a certain set of examples yeah sure
so I think you asked a couple things in
there so I'll just I'll try to answer
this one by one so the one thing you
asked is where models gets stored and so
if I heard you correctly so one way to
do that is to store the model on
something like a on a bucket whatever
cloud provider it is that you're using
you can store it in some central
location and then you can just access
the model via an API call that's one way
to do it if you just get outputted as a
file in terms of evaluating if a model
is actually good that's the it sort of
depends on what your use case is there's
different metrics for evaluating how how
effective a model is in some cases you
might want to use accuracy which is just
given a hundred samples how many of
these did it correctly predict but
that's not going to always be the case
in something like if you have a medical
if you're building a model for medicine
that's detecting some very rare disease
if you just say that every case is
negative if you're gonna have a very
high accuracy rate but that's obviously
not helpful for picking up whether or
not it's
the model works so then you would use
something called a precision to recall
their things co-operators may recall to
actually evaluate whether or not this is
a good model and you can do that using
different hyper parameters so for all of
these models there's different values
that you can set when you're when you're
building the model so the best way to do
it would just be to basically train
several models using these different
numbers and just see which one is the
best for your use case there's
definitely bit of trial and error in
this and that's as you do this a bit
more you get some intuition but there at
the end of the day it's a lot of just I
guess guesswork loosely hey next
question hi thanks we talked was very
informative you told us that you tend to
flow moves into the director of carers
and influence interface but I think you
had one sentence that said not a hundred
percent now is there some interesting
case where you said okay there there's
this new tensorflow that carers thing
that's not compatible to if people are
using carrots now so which would prevent
you from moving to TF dot Kira's thanks
for the question I think the the biggest
pull at this point would be if for some
reason you didn't want to use tensorflow
as the underlying engine um in terms of
the API I don't know anything specific
that is significant enough to say don't
move to TF Harris but yeah I guess that
would be the one you know the specific
use case I could think of any other
questions thanks for the talk I think
you're going in an interesting direction
of effort in the floor when you think
will it be stable released like right
now it's beta I'm honestly not sure I I
think there's it's sometime in 2019 is
what I keep hearing but definitely keep
a lookout for it so the Alpha was
released in March and the beta was
released in last month so I would expect
it to be yeah sometimes
soonish okay thank you yep any other
questions
hello I'm wondering what's the
relationship between tensorflow and all
these other tensorflow libraries that
you mentioned like TF agent EF
probability like is it because of the
distribution scheme that's the same or
what's the relationship between all
these entities sure
so tensorflow in it of itself has these
like these raw variables I guess if you
will and like the ability to build
models like you would use something like
numpy so effectively something like tens
of flow data agents it's just built
using these tensor flow objects so as
you might implement something like like
a Q learning function and that's just
basically using the tensor flow objects
underneath the hood so it's just built
on top of it's similar to how something
might be built on top of a numpy these
are just built on top of tensor flow
other questions okay can I ask a
question please
I teach young people and they are moving
through things at a rate of knots some
of them and they are tremendously
interested in machine learning and
artificial intelligence if they took
your set of tutorials on this subject
and work through it independently or
with the teachers help how easy or
difficult would it be do you think for a
simple project so I think there's a
there's a ton of examples available for
like some of the simpler ones like if
you wanted to do something like computer
vision or something using natural
language processing um there there is a
lot of there are a lot of resources
available so I think it would be enough
to get someone started a lot of these
introductory courses both on like
Udacity and Coursera also go through
some of the more common examples so
those would definitely be another good
place to go but I think it's yeah just
for a first simple stuff I think it's
pretty easy to get started with this
okay thank you yeah sorry just to
quickly carry on from what you were just
saying about the Udacity course I was
just interested in Oh
tensorflow to or is that still talking
about the old times of flow with I don't
know some some sort of detail about the
new tenth of flow coming in there it
should use tender flow - it should be an
introduction to using using myself
specifically okay next question
thank you for to talk just seen that
care has been integrated how the
estimators I want to I mean that make
sense to continue using s Tomatoes with
the new curves integration thank you
sure that very good question so the the
estimators are not being I guess further
developed so they will long-term be
deprecated in favor of the Karis api's
they're still there but I wouldn't
expect any new changes to come to them
anytime in the near future
okay next question no more questions you
sure I get stick around for a couple of
minutes to if anyone has any you know
what's the talk offline okay can you put
your hands together for a round of
applause for Brad zero thank you